Phobias guy that was promoting
something recently that Hillary was 50%
reptilian. 50%. I've
heard 30% I can believe,
but 50 50 is a wall half.
Yeah. See if you can find that.
Someone said she has 50% reptilian blood.
Well,
you know that was a David Eick thing for
the longest time. The reptilians. Yeah,
I remember he was saying he
won't talk about that now.
Apparently he's angry when people bring
up reptilians cause it's embarrassing
because he was like, I
shouldn't have believed that.
Yeah. What's a fucking fool?
Heart will hit.
And then he became way more mainstream
and then the internet came along and it
could be like, hey, you remember
that fucking reptilian thing?
That's the crazy shit. [inaudible] have
an answer for that either. Oh yeah.
I was just making that up for whatever,
what I was back in the
early days of internet or I
believed it or like I believe
that. Now I realize how crazy
that was. Yeah, you can say that,
but not like don't bring it up. Yeah.
There's, I mean, look, there's fucking,
there's real conspiracy.
You know that, um,
that story about that journalist that
was killed by the Saudis this week.
[inaudible] that's real,
that he was killed. Yeah.
They finally admitted that they
killed him. Saudis did. Yeah.
They said that they killed him in a fight,
which is if you see the guy, he like,
fuck, this guy's not fighting
anyone. Yeah. Like, and some of the,
the crown prince's top people,
top security people had been released
apparently probably gave him a fucking
hundred million dollars and said,
go chill on a beach somewhere. Wow.
Two was like tied in a car accident
this week and I'll quote that.
Kill a lot of journalists, man. No,
not a journalist. Info wars. Real News.
Twitter band after MSM
outcry over Hillary satire.
So it was a satire piece.
I just found the piece and I was like,
there's no way that this is real.
They thought it was satire.
I don't know who did, but can I just
tell you about, about Hillary Clinton,
his DNA test proving she's only half
lizard person only like she's Jewish.
She relates it to,
to clear her name.
Did you know Elizabeth Warren released
that thing that says that she's got
actual native American blood
but it's literally like one,
100024th fucking million trillion.
Wow.
She has like the smallest amount of
a Ben Shapiro tweeted about that.
What he said, Oh fuck Jay. We've tried to
find it. Your great, great, great, great,
great grandfather. But it was something
else, but I forgot what it was.
See if we could find it.
But I think I'm 1.6% African.
I did one of those DNA
tests. Yeah. And I'm done.
If standards goodbye.
I think I'm at least 10 times more African
native American. Wow. Um,
that's how ridiculous it is.
I might be wrong with these numbers
because Jamie and I were trying to work it
out and we're both stupid.
It's fun. She released that.
It's like c instead of going
like, oh, I guess I'm not that.
She was lying and she was also lied
to. Probably her family's like, well,
you know we have native enough. So I'm
like, oh cool. But that does happen.
People do check like Jamie.
Jamie thought he had a gang gang of
native American in him. He's a chat.
Supposedly do. It's hard to prove.
It's from what I'm trying to find out.
I can't wait to do one of those tests.
I just have up to see if
I'm over 90% 7% Jewish,
like under 97% Jewish.
Mine is almost exactly what I thought.
It's mostly Italian.
It's some other European like Irish and
English. You've got to be part monkey.
Yeah. There's some, there's
some neanderthal. I found
the editorial in there. Yeah.
87% more than the average person.
No,
he was trying to prove that he was
minorities who claim victim hood. I know,
I know. To take the cut,
they swab your mouth.
So of course he found an native American
and just doesn't making out with them
and then swap and I know like uh,
came up kind of weird.
They're like 98% native American
so we can get a blood test.
So of he wasn't any minority except he
was like 2% in the end are tall and he
goes, oh you white. My people out. You
raped by people and that's great. Yeah.